During the lifetime
of your application,
you can expect the amount
of allocated memory
to change quite
frequently-- for example,
needing to allocate a
whole load of bitmaps
for your social media stream
or plotting a new jogging
path that takes your user
past a trendy new donut shop.
What's tricky, though, is
seeing how these allocations
can impact your performance.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And with the help of a snazzy
new tool in Android Studio,
you can get a better sense of
how your application is using
memory, which can help you track
down any related performance
issues before your
users start to notice.
And these issues are now easier
to solve with Android Studio's
new Memory Monitor utility.
This tool can give a
quick visual overview
of how your application
is using memory over time.
On the top left of
the window, you'll
see your currently
connected device,
and on the right, the
selected application
that you'd like to monitor.
If you have multiple
devices or apps active,
this is where you'll
select between them.
The graph in the middle of
the window is a stacked graph.
That is, the amount of memory
that your application is
currently using is
shown in dark blue,
while the unallocated memory
that's available to be used
is shown in light
blue right above it.
Over time, this
graph will continue
to update, showing you
changes in your memory usage.
Now, in a world where your app
isn't doing much of anything,
you should see a flat
graph just like this one.
From a performance
perspective, this
is actually an ideal scenario.
See, as your app allocates
and frees memory,
you'll see the allocative
amount fluctuate in your graph
at the same time.
Any time your allocated memory
drops by a significant amount,
that's a signal that a garbage
collection event has occurred.
These GC events aren't generally
a noticeable performance
problem.
However, a lot of them
occurring over and over
and over again in a
short period of time
can actually lead to
performance issues.
The more time you're
spending doing GCs,
the less time you'll
have to do other stuff,
like rendering or
streaming audio.
To enable the Memory Monitor,
start Android Studio,
connect a physical
device, and run your app.
Then go back and select Memory
Monitor from the Tools menu.
Once the monitor is
running, a new tab
at the bottom of your
screen will show up
with all the
relevant information.
While Memory Monitor will help
you know the general health
and performance
of your system, it
doesn't help you track down
any problems related to that.
For that, you actually need
something more powerful,
like the Memory Heap tool,
which will allow you to find out
where in your code objects are
being created but not released,
created and not used, or created
new when you could have been
reusing them from
existing objects.
While Java's memory-managed
environment makes it easy
for you to work with memory,
it takes a lot of effort
to ensure that those processes
keep your app running
at top speed, which is
why you need to check out
the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns
content for other great tips
and tricks on efficient memory
usage.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community as well,
for in-the-trenches advice
from other developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
Perf Matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]